The world's gonna die. I can feel it coming and I think about Ruth
How did she survive out there on her own as broken as she is
Lila, this is your mother
Does she have...
yes, but not like yours
Our abilities can't fix things if something's broken it stays broken
Lila's different
She can see the colors. What do they look like?
I've never seen them. It's like an echo
Moving over everything fast like a race
It's gotten harder for us to stay in hiding
They know
There's not much time. You cannot be putting her in danger again and not leaving
This woman can affect the energy of the earth
We can help you, there are tests we can run
A new world is coming. I'm not scared anymore